Several statistics we can compute in a pretty straightforward way if the list L is sorted.
Let's imagine that these are list of values that we're concerned about and I put little
pointy things on it to say that this is now sorted from smallest to largest.
If this L is sorted the minimum value is sitting here in the very first position--so it's L(â‚€),
the maximum is sitting all the way at the end here--L(n-â‚ ),
midpoint is just the average of those two--so we can look up the minimum, the maximum
add them together and divided by 2, and the median is just whoever is
sitting in the middle of this list once it's sorted.
In this case, all of these operations run in Î˜(1) constant time, given that the list is sorted.
Things like the mean or the mode aren't quite so straightforward to do on a sorted
list like this but these four we can do very, very quickly.
Just to practice this idea, here's little quiztistics. Here's a sorted list of two digit numbers.
I want you to find the midpoint and the median of this list
and then tell me what's the mean of those two values.
You can write it in this box.